[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوش
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
يا ليتما الفراعات يخبرنا اين تولت باهلها
السفن السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
المحصله في اللغه ليست النتيجه
الكلمتان ليستا
مترادفتين وحصل لا تعني حدثا ليس بالضبط
هناك قوتان تجذبان الدلو وبالرياضيات نحسب
المحصله هذه محصله لانها مجموع اكثر من
شيء وعندما تقول كسبت 100 دينار فانفقت 20
دينارا على الطعام وثلاثين على الملابس
وفي المحصله بقي معي 50 دينارا فهذا تعبير
صحيح
يقول ابن فارس في مقاييس اللغه الحاء
والصاد واللام اصلا واحد منقاس وهو جمع
الشيء ولذلك سميت حوصله الطائر لانه يجمع
فيها
للطائر حوصله يختزن فيها الحبه ليخرجه من
بعد ويطعم افراخه والحوصله فيها ما جمعه
من هنا وهناك ومن الاصل حصل اشتقت العرب
المحصول والمحاصيل
والحصاله في مصر كانت في الماضي فخارا
وفضيله الحصاله القديمه انها تحبس النقود
فلا سبيل للطفل ان يستعيد القروش التي
وفرها
وافت الحصاله الفخاريه انه انها تكسر في
يوم العيد ثم اصبحت الحصاله علبه ملونه
جميله
ولا تكسر ولكن افتها ان الطفل كلما اشتهى
شراء شيء سار الى فتحها قبل الاوان
ونعود الى الاصل حصل فقد اشتقت منه لغتنا
في دول المغرب العربي التعبير تحصل على
ومع البيئات الاعلاميه التي جمعت بين
ابناء هذه اللغه من شتى البلدان دخل الفعل
تحصل الى لسان المشارقه وقد نستخدم الفعل
حصل في غير موضعه كان نقول حصل معي حادث
وذلك فرارا من التكرار في القول حدث معي
حادث نحن لا نريد ان نكرر حدث وحادث اللغه
ايها الساده تحتال على نفسها وتكسر بعض
قواعدها في سبيل جمال التعبير وقد ينسى
المترجم نفسه فيسمي موظف الضرائب ناقلا
للتعبير الاجنبي فيقول رجل الضرائب ولكن
هناك كلمه واحده بالعربيه تصيب الهدف وهي
كلمه
محصل وهذه مره اخرى من الفصيح
واما قولهم في مصر
حصلني بمعنى اتبعني فابتداعي الفعل حصل من
الافعال الجميله التي يستعملها صاحب اللغه
الانيقه استعمالا صحيحا وما زال هذا الفعل
يملك قدره اشتقاقيه لم تستخدم بعد
فلماذا مثلا لا نقول الاستحصال والانحصال
والاحتصال تطور اللغه قد يقتضي استخراج
اشتقاقات اخرى من الفعل حصل اللغه العربيه
لغه اشتقاق ولهذا فصدرها يتسع باستمرار
وهذا كما لا يخفى على احد تحصيل حاصل
[موسيقى]
من بدائع التوريه مع توخي الصدق في موطن
الخوف قول ابي بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
وقد اقبل رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهو رديفه عام الهجره فقيل له من هذا يا
ابا بكر فقال رجل يهديني السبيل
ومن الكنايات في كلام رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم قوله اياكم وخضراء الدمن يريد
بها المراه الحسناء في منبت السوء ذلك ان
الريح تجمع الدمم اعزكم الله في البقعه من
الارض فاذا اصابه مطر نبت عنده ونبت غض
يهتز فيحسبه الناظر طيبا ولا يدرك انه قد
نبت في منبت سوء يقول فلا تنكح هذه المراه
الحسناء لجمالها ومنبتها خبيث كالدمن فان
العرق دساس
يقول الشاعر وقد ينبت المرعى على دمن
الثرى وتبقى حزازات النفوس كما هي
[موسيقى]
تقول العرب في امثالها ماز راسك والسيف
فما معنى هذا المثل
يريدون بقولهم ماز راسك والسيف اي باعد
راسك من السيف والمخاطب رجل اسمه مازن روي
عن الاصمعي انه قال اصل ذلك ان رجلا يقال
له مازن اسر رجلا وكان رجل يطلب الماسوره
بذحل اي بثار فقال له مازي راسك والسيف اي
مازن نحي راسك لاني ساضرب بالسيف فنحى
راسه
فضرب الرجل عنق الاسير
ومن امثالهم الليل واهضام الوادي اي اتقي
ان تسلك ليلا في احضان الوادي والهضم هو
المكان المطمئن من الارض
وكما تلاحظون في المثل الاول حذفوا حرف
النون من اسم مازن فقالوا مازر راسك
والسيف وهذا في اللغه العربيه من الترخيم
كان تقول عائش بدا من عائشه وفاطم بدلا من
فاطمه وصاح بدلا من صاحب
قال احد الحكماء عجبت للبخيل يستعجل الفقر
الذي فر منه ويفوته الغنى الذي سعى اليه
فيعيش في الدنيا عيش الفقراء ويحاسب في
الاخره حساب الاغنياء
سئل ابن عباس عن الغضب والحزن ايهما اشد
فقال مخرجهما واحد واللفظ مختلف فمن نازع
من يقوى عليه اظهره ويسمى غضبا ومن نازع
من يعجز عنه كتمه ويسمى حزنا
[موسيقى]
حرد
يستعملها العامه في بلاد الشام بمعنى زعل
وكلا المفردتين حرد وزعل من العربيه
الفصحى وبحسب سيبويه حرد يحرد حردا اذا
غضب وتعني استاء وسخط ولكني وقعت على
استعمال اخر لهذه المفرده في كتاب الله
تعالى في سوره نون يقول تعالى وغدوا على
حرد قادرين
وقرات فيما قرات ان العرب تقول حاردت
السنه اذا لم يكن فيها مطر
وحاردت الناقه اذا لم يكن فيها لبن فاخذوا
الحرب بمعنى المنع وتلك قصه اصحاب الجنه
الذين اقسموا ان يمنعوا من عطائها الجنه
بمعنى البستان طبعا ان يمنعوا من عطائها
المساكين والفقراء
نتش يستعمل العاب كلمه نتشا للتعبير عن
قضم لقمه من اللحم او الطعام وهي كلمه
فصحى تعني جذب او نتفه ولها معان اخرى
بحسب استعمالها فيقال نتش الجراد الارض اي
اكل نباتها ونتش الشيء اي اخذ منه وتاتي
بمعنى القليل يقال ما اخذ من الشيء الا
نتشا قليلا
نغصه يقال نغص في العاميه للاشاره الى امر
حال دون اكتمال الفرحه وهي كلمه فصحى تعني
لم تتم هناء امر ما تستخدم مع التشديد
نغصه بمعنى كدر او قطع ما هو محبب
[موسيقى]
يقولون امراه مرضعه والصواب امراه مرضع
بحذف التاء لانها صفه خاصه بالاناث لا
تاتي التاء في هذه الصفات الا اذا اردت
وصفها بتلك الحاله فلو قلت مرضعه تكون قد
اردت وصفها بذلك حال ارضاعها طفلها وهو
لاقم ثديها يقول تعالى يوم ترونها تذهل كل
مرضعه عما ارضعت
يقولون هو معمر بالكسر اذا عاش طويلا
والصواب معمر بالفتح بصيغه اسم المفعول
وهو الذي اطال الله عمره يقول تعالى وما
يعمر من معمر ولا ينقص من عمره الا في
كتاب
[موسيقى]
وقف اعرابي معوج الفم امام احد الولاه
والقى عليه قصيده في الثناء عليه التماسا
لمكافاه لكن الوالي لم يعطيه شيئا وساله
ما بال فمك معوجا فاجاب الشاعر لعله عقوبه
من الله لكثره الثناء بالباطل على بعض
الناس
ومن طرائف القدماء ان اعرابيا سال شخصا
معروفا ببخله ما الفرح بعد المصيبه فاجاب
ان تحلف على الضيف بالاكل ويتحجج بالصيام
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر عن بيت من الشعر ينتهي
بكلمه وطني
ووصلتني منكم مشاركات رائعه جدا استعرض
معكم بعضا منها
البدايه مشاركه من ايناس تقول انت البلاد
التي تعطي هويتها من لا يحبك يبقى دون ما
وطني تقول هذا البيت للكبير نزار قباني
رحمه الله محمد يقول ويبدو ان الابيات من
تاليفه فيما يبدو قلبي ملاذ لعصفور على
فنن يشدو بلحن حزين طيله الزمن يقول وهو
يراني غير منتبه لا تشردن بعيدا واستمع
شجني اني تعبت من التحليق من غصن منفى الى
غصن سميته وطني الله يا محمد هذا محمد بو
ثران
تقول جسمي معي غير ان الروح عندكم فالجسم
في غربه والروح في وطني
واحمد الخزاعي يقول انهاجني الشوق للاوطان
عدت الى قلبي لاحضن ما يحويه من وطني
مشاركه من اسماء تقول اهواك مثل غريب لم
يجد وطنا حتى توسم في عينيك اوطانا
وفاطم تقول وانا غريب الدار في وطني محمود
درويش
جابر المري يقول
بيت بالنبطي طبعا بالدارجه العاميه فين
ضجت ولا وطاني من زماني طنا اوفى بشر
لابتي واغلى بلاده وطني
ومشاركه من مصطفى يقول من زقزقات عصافير
الصباح ارى صلاه مستغفر سميتها وطني
اما انا فاذا سمحتم لي بالمشاركه فاقول
كاني هدهد قد عاد من سبقي فلا بلقيس
تعرفني ولا هم صدقون بائي افتش في سماء
الله عن وطن
وتكبر في يرغم الغيم كل نوازع الظمائي
واقول ايضا
اهواك مثل غريبا لم يجد وطنا حتى توسم في
عينيك اوطانا
واشكر لكم هذا التفاعل الجميل وهذه
المشاركات الرائحه
[موسيقى]
قال بعضهم لا نحبه ولا نسبه فقال اخرون بل
نسبه ونلعنه
الحجاج ابن يوسف الثقفي
كان الحجاج بن يوسف شخصيه خلافيه في حياته
وبعد موته وحتى يوم الناس هذا ولد في
الطائف موطن عشيرته ثقيف مع مولد الدوله
الامويه وشب فصيحا يساعد اباه في تعليم
الصبيان عندما كان الحجاج في الرابعه
والعشرين من عمره نشات على مقربه منه في
مكه المكرمه دوله ضرار ففي مكه اعلن عبد
الله بن الزبير نفسه خليفه حكم ابن الزبير
الحجاز وسير اخاه مصعبا الى العراق فحكمها
ولم يبقى لبني اميه سوى الشام ومصرى وبعد
سنين قلائل تولى الخلافه في الشام رجل قوي
هو عبد الملك بن مروان
ملا الحجاج التعليم وقاده وطموحه الى
السياسه لكنه رمى بنظره بعيدا فارتحل الى
الشام وانضم الى شرطه عبد الملك اصبح
قائدا سياسيا راى رجاله مره ياكلون في غير
موعد اكل ودعوه الى طعامهم غير انه حرق
عليهم خيمتهم
وعاقبهم فشكاه قائده الى الخليفه
اصلح الخليفه بينهما لكنه ادرك ان بين
رجاله من يملك قلبا قويا
مضى عبد الملك الى العراق لمحاربه مصعب بن
الزبير واصطحب الحجاج
قتل مصعب وعاد العراق الى حظيره الدوله
الامويه لكن عبد الله بن الزبير ظل في مكه
وظل ينادي بالخلافه في الحجاز فوجه اليه
عبد الملك الحجاج في جيش كبير كانت فرصه
الحجاج ليستعمل قسوته
احتمى ابن الزبير بالحرم المكي فضرب
الحجاج الكعبه بالمنجنيق وحاصر الحرم حتى
قضى على ابن الزبير وقتله وصلبه لم يبالي
بقرابه ابن الزبير من الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم ولا بان امه هي اسماء بنت ابي
بكر ذات النطاقين
فلماذا يمتنع كثيرون علان الحجاج ذلك انه
قضى على الانشقاق في الدوله الاسلاميه
ومنع ازدواجيه الخلافه
قال له عبد الملك في ساعه صفاء صف لنفسك
فقال الحجاج انا حقود حسود ولا اعرف رجلا
اشد مني اقداما على الدم
استقام امر الخلافه لبنيه اميه غير ان
الخوارج في العراق كانوا يسببون قلقا
كانوا محاربين اشداء ومن لم يكن معهم من
اهل العراق كان يتخذ موقفا وسطا فلا هو مع
الخلافه ولا هو مع الخوارج
وارسل عبد الملك الحجاج الى العراق واليا
وبدا عهده في الكوفه حيث القى خطبته
المشهوره فهدد الناس وحملهم على السيف كي
يخرج معه لقتال الخوارج
وكان ان مات عبد الملك وتولى الخلافه تبنه
الوليد الذي ازداد تمسكا بالحجاج
مات الحجاج عن خمس وخمسين سنه كان يسفك
الدماء لادنى شبهه ولكن كثيرين يفضلون
النظر الى الصوره الواسعه فيقولون انه حفظ
على الدوله الاسلاميه تماسكها
انا ابن جلال وطلاع الثنايا متى اضع
العمامه تعرفوني
[موسيقى]
كان هناك فيلسوف يدعى بن رشد
رحل
وكثيرنا لا نعرف متى عاش ومتى رحل ولكن
نعرف انه صاحب فكر بقي فكره حتى اليوم
وكان هناك مهندس معماري يدعى سنان معمار
اغا
وسنان عم راف القصور في الدوله العثمانيه
فرحل سنان وظلت قصوره باقيه شامخه
مضى عهد بن رشد في غياب وظل الفكر في ابد
الحضور وكانت دوله فيها سنان يعمرها بالاف
القصور
مضت حتى طواها الدهر نسيا وذكر سنان حي في
العصور السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]